fans are waiting with breath it was
baited for the final episodes of
stranger things and they are literally
chomping at the bit to know all the
behind the scenes secrets of the show
let's take a look of who's got the
spiciest info from the show at this
moment
there's a crew favorite like any aspect
of life there's just gonna be people
that you favor more and sure this might
seem kind of mean but hey let's be
honest most parents have a favorite
child so why wouldn't the crew have a
favorite cast member according to an
interview from the high chair in a case
of answer now a crew member sheepishly
admitted that Millie Bobby Brown is
definitely the crew's favorite sorry to
the rest but the writing's on the wall
now the wall may be upside down but
still
it's a tiring show while being an actor
seems to be a dog's breakfast of a
career with assistance fancy premieres
and all the craft table treats a tummy
could handle however the hours are most
definitely long so it makes sense that
people will be needing all the downtime
possible especially Charlie Heaton who
was Notorious for napping it up all over
set from his trailer to just offset
we've got ourselves a sleepy guy
Off Script sure the actors on set are
younger than your average cast but from
Noah schnapp to Millie Bobby Brown These
are some professionals to the core but
they also love to Spill the hot Goss and
according to these two in real life
besties of all the cast members who go
off book all the way Finn wolfhard loves
to mix it up line-wise and while there's
a few scenes that are improvised from
being in on it also known as when Millie
Bobby Brown's character collapsed into
Finn's arms from Pure emotional
exhaustion but whatever the reason why
Finn loves the Off Script ways is for
sure working
breaking is the funnest part let's be
frank everyone loves a blooper wheel
entire television shows have been based
around this concept and let's be honest
the post-credit blooper scenes of a
movie may be the whole reason to sit
through a movie and when it comes to who
on the cast was the ultimate in breaking
it could definitely be counted on Gayton
Matarazzo to bring in the funny and
co-star Sadie sink can attest to Gayton
being too too funny it's been Gayton she
had a tough time keeping it together in
whatever scene the two of them are in
together calling his style of Comedy
genius here's hoping we get to see the
lighter side of Gayton in his projects
to come an actor prepares Noah schnapp
who portrays the sweet will buyers from
day one had intensely emotional scenes
and for the most prestigious actor a day
of high intensity emotions is a
challenge but a way to get into it for
those crying scenes Noah ironically
enough turned to movies a trick learned
from fellow co-star Millie Bobby Brown
when the tears needed to flow Noah
watches the sad scene from a favorite
movie and it gets the job done according
to Noah the movie that does the trick
these days is the a24 critics fave
everything everywhere all at once
the breaker gets broken
and while we all now know that Gayton
Matarazzo is funny who's the one to make
the Breaky break look no further than
Caleb McLaughlin the actor who portrays
Lucas Sinclair has a laugh they can
break a thousand scenes and according to
Gayton Caleb has a laugh to make a stone
statue giggle oh so cute
music to make up to
fans truly cannot get enough of the
upside down vecna and all things monster
on Stranger Things the special effects
are award-worthy and spellbinding but
what that actually means for the actors
is more time in the makeup chair and
long long hours of makeup application
can make the mind wander especially if
you're being covered in Prosthetics and
literally cannot move a muscle in these
scenarios it's good to have music on
your side according to lead makeup
artist Jamie Campbell Bower says that in
tough times of makeup application
playing music makes the day go better
and from all the music in the world to
pass the time they decide to pump
Marilyn Manson to go hand in hand with
the monster theme The Beautiful People
indeed
Uber Eats to the rescue a big set secret
is craft Services is usually the bomb
actors and set guests alike flock to
enjoy the trees to break up the long
hours of shoot day unfortunately actor
Noah schnapp had to admit that the food
on set is really just okay there are
four actors like Noah tended to make
their own food and ubereats ordered on
the regular wonder what the vechna's
go-to order is
let's get rowdy
in a high chair interview with Gayton
Matarazzo when asked what the tone of
the set was like the one and only word
that came to mind was Rowdy and that can
definitely be felt with a tone and
chemistry of the set and Gayton said his
character in season two got to spend all
his scenes with characters Lucas and Max
and come season 3 he will spend most
scenes with Steve Robin and Priya so the
partying is apparent and I think I can
speak for all fans when I ask invite us
to the next Jam please and thanks
one take Tammy when it comes to
professionalism onset young actors do
not tend to have the best reputation
coming from the era of the low hands and
the lovados reputations May precede
child actors before they even hit the
set however the stranger things cast is
breaking the mold once again by bringing
the seriousness and when it comes to
preparation being on point actor Sadie
sink has confirmed that the actors who
could do a scene in one take award goes
to Joe Kiri who plays Steve and Gayton
Matarazzo who portrays Dustin Henderson
according to Sadie these two actors are
self-prepared it's in and out of scenes
like a Fiddler's Elbow baby
now with a Spiller fun fact about Noah
schnapp this boy always needs a tide to
go stick constantly as someone who is a
self-identified Spiller Noah who has
been known to ruin a costume or two on
the first day of shooting a movie he
ended up spilling chocolate sauce all
along his back here's hoping laundry's
on set
Maya Hawk's fave scene
celebrity Offspring Maya Hawk joins
stranger things in season 3 and
immediately became a fan favorite with
her portrayal of Robin Buckley but if
the people were wondering which scene
was a favorite to Maya herself she had
the answer up and ready in season 3 a
sincere two-hander between Robin and
Steve at the video store that was shot
in one take was the scene of the moment
for her a chance for Maya and Joe Kiri
to truly connect as actors is all she
really wanted and the audience and fans
were living for it it was perfect but
the shootout in one shot near the end of
season four there's a seminal shootout
scene yeah it was
crazy upon reading the script for that
scene director Sean Levy had a stroke of
creative inspiration that made him
realize to properly capture the essence
of this scene he wanted to shoot the
shootout in one shot and while movies
often employed this camera work think
the walk to the Copa and Goodfellas
executing this kind of camera work in
the fast pace of a television show is a
great feat and props to director Sean
Levy because this scene had all the
feels and more
color matters costume designer of
stranger things Amy Paris has remarked
that the colors of the clothing really
matter with subtle hints to keep the
audience in keeping with the emotional
story they want to tell it's also fun
tying certain outfits together with
colors and pieces for example the colors
remained dark and Moody for scenes in
Russia and then they pop hard when the
pool days come so if you're an audience
member wondering why they're feeling
what they're feeling look no further
than color theory
wild rehearsal times
the cast and director executive producer
Sean Levy all could agree that the
shootout scene for the series was the
most intense planning for a scene that
will only be shot in one take means
everyone has to be on their A-game all
the time Non-Stop and in terms of
rehearsing the cast had to be relentless
behind the scenes the cast was
choreographing and getting prepared to
do it all in one take therefore the cast
through and through all agreed that
prepping for that shot was the rehearsal
of all rehearsals
hope you enjoyed learning all the ins
and outs of what makes the behind the
scenes of stranger things such a true
Jam which tidbit made you smile the most
like comment and subscribe to the thing
celebrity for all your upside down needs